In the ever evolving landscape of
agriculture, drones have emerged as
innovative tools that are reshaping the
way farmers operate. These unmanned
aerial vehicles are not just a passing
trend. They represent a significant leap
forward in agricultural technology. As
farmers face the dual challenges of
increasing food production and managing
resources sustainably, drones offer a
solution that enhances efficiency and
effectiveness in various farming
practices. Drones come in various types,
each designed to serve specific purposes
in the agricultural sector. The two
primary categories are fixed wing drones
and multi-rotor drones. Fixed-wing
drones are akin to miniature airplanes
capable of covering large areas quickly
due to their aerodynamic design. They
are particularly useful for largecale
farms where extensive crop monitoring is
essential. On the other hand,
multi-rotor drones, which resemble
helicopters, are highly maneuverable and
can hover in place, making them ideal
for detailed inspections and targeted
applications. Each type of drone brings
unique capabilities to the table,
allowing farmers to choose the right
tool for their specific needs. One of
the most transformative applications of
drones in agriculture is crop
monitoring. Equipped with highresolution
cameras and advanced imaging technology,
drones can capture detailed imagery of
fields from above. This capability
allows farmers to assess plant health
with remarkable precision. By utilizing
infrared light, drones can identify
variations in vegetation health that may
not be visible to the naked eye. This
means that issues such as pest
infestations, nutrient deficiencies, or
water stress can be detected promptly,
enabling farmers to take action before
these problems escalate. The ability to
monitor crops in real time not only
enhances productivity, but also
contributes to more sustainable farming
practices. In addition to crop
monitoring, drones play a crucial role
in irrigation planning. With the ability
to create detailed maps of fields,
drones help farmers optimize water
usage, an increasingly important
consideration in an era of climate
change and water scarcity. By analyzing
the data collected, farmers can identify
areas that require more or less water,
thus ensuring that every drop is used
efficiently. Advanced features such as
thermal cameras further enhance this
capability by allowing farmers to assess
soil temperature, which is critical for
understanding moisture levels and making
informed irrigation decisions. This
level of precision in water management
can lead to significant cost savings and
improved crop yields. The significance
of data collection cannot be overstated
when it comes to the transformative role
of drones in agriculture. Drones gather
critical information that can be
analyzed to reveal patterns and insights
that are invaluable for decision-making.
For instance, by analyzing historical
data collected by drones, farmers can
determine the optimal times for
fertilizer application, leading to more
effective use of resources.
Additionally, understanding the timing
of harvest can be enhanced by drone
data, allowing farmers to maximize yield
and minimize waste. The integration of
drone collected data with farm
management software creates a
comprehensive understanding of farm
health, enabling farmers to make
informed decisions that drive
productivity and profitability. However,
the adoption of drone technology in
agriculture is not without its
challenges. Regulatory considerations
pose a significant hurdle for many
farmers. The need for licenses,
adherence to flying regulations, and
understanding airspace restrictions can
be daunting. It is essential for farmers
to seek guidance from local agricultural
extension offices, which can provide
valuable information on compliance and
best practices. By navigating these
regulatory waters, farmers can unlock
the full potential of drones in their
operations. Despite these challenges,
the benefits of utilizing drones far
outweigh the regulatory hurdles.
Improved crop yields, reduced costs, and
enhanced sustainability are just a few
of the advantages that come with
integrating drone technology into
farming practices. As advancements in
drone technology continue to unfold, the
future looks promising. Exciting
developments are on the horizon,
including the potential for drones to
assist with pest control and
pollination. Imagine a future where
drones autonomously detect and address
agricultural challenges, applying
targeted treatments or even pollinating
crops in areas where traditional methods
fall short. This vision of the future is
not merely a dream. It is becoming a
reality as farmers and technologists
collaborate to push the boundaries of
what is possible. Drones are already
being used to spray crops with
precision, minimizing chemical use and
reducing environmental impact. The
prospect of drones performing tasks that
were once labor intensive or
time-conuming opens up new avenues for
efficiency and productivity in
agriculture. As we stand on the brink of
this agricultural revolution, it is
crucial for farmers, stakeholders, and
enthusiasts to engage with the ongoing
advancements in agricultural technology.
Sharing experiences with drones in
farming can foster a community of
innovation and support. Whether it's
discussing successes, challenges, or
lessons learned, open dialogue can lead
to a deeper understanding of how best to
integrate these powerful tools into
farming practices. In conclusion, the
transformative role of drones in
agriculture is undeniable. From crop
monitoring to irrigation planning, data
collection to pest control, drones are
changing the way farmers approach their
work. While regulatory considerations
may pose challenges, the benefits of
improved crop yields and reduced costs
are compelling reasons to embrace this
technology. As we look to the future, we
can envision a world where drones
autonomously detect and address
agricultural challenges, paving the way
for a more sustainable and productive
farming landscape.
Let us stay engaged with these
advancements and share our experiences
as together we can cultivate a brighter
future for agriculture.